do not spoil what you have
by desiring what you have not
remember that what you now have was once
among the things
you only hoped for
he who is not satisfied with a little
is satisfied with nothing
of all the means to ensure happiness
throughout the whole life
by far the most important
is the acquisition of friends
death does not concern us
because as long as we exist
death is not here
and when it does come
we no longer exist
you don't develop courage by being happy
in your relationships every day you
develop it by surviving difficult times
in challenging adversity
not what we have
but
what we enjoy
constitutes our abundance
it is not so much our friends help that
helps us
as the confident knowledge that they
will help us
the art of living well
in the art of dying well are one
the fool's life is empty of gratitude
and full of fears
its course lies wholly toward the future
nothing is sufficient for the person who
finds sufficiency too little
pleasure is the beginning and end of a
happy life
the greatest fruit of justice
is serenity
knowing your flaws is the first step to
health
it is better for you to be free of fear
lying upon a palate
then to have a golden couch and a rich
table
and be full of trouble
be moderate in order to taste the joys
of life in abundance
[Music]
there is nothing terrible in life for
someone who truly understands
that there is nothing terrible in
non-life
the greater the difficulty
the more the glory in surmounting it
he who least needs tomorrow
will most gladly greet tomorrow
the time when you should most of all
withdraw into yourself
is when you are forced to be in a crowd
let no one delay the study of philosophy
while young nor weary of it when old
the most important consequence of
self-sufficiency
is freedom
[Music]
we should look for someone to eat and
drink with before looking for something
to eat and drink
of all the things which wisdom acquires
to produce the blessedness of the
complete life
for the greatest is the possession of
friendship
if a person fights the clear evidence of
his senses
he will never be able to share ingenuine
tranquility
[Music]
if thou wilt make a man happy
add not unto his riches
but take away from his desires
if you shape your life according to
nature
you will never be poor
if according to people's opinions
you will never be rich
[Music]
contented poverty
is an honorable estate
therefore
foolish is the man who says that he
fears death
not because it will cause pain when it
arrives
but because anticipation of it is
painful
[Music]
don't spoil the impression of what you
have by wanting what you don't have
[Music]
to get great pleasure
you need to limit yourself
the life of a fool is bleak and full of
fear
because he puts everything aside for the
future
[Music]
do not avoid doing small services they
will think that you are also capable of
big ones
[Music]
it is better for you to be unhappy right
away
than being happy without reason
happiness
is the repression of suffering and
anxiety
don't even dare trust a wife
that says you're always right
in old age we all regret not having
killed laziness in ourselves
do not marry after 40
because marriage is not provided by
nature
admonition instead of hate
smile instead of contempt
[Music]